- [Narrator] Schools across the US
are struggling to stay open.
While most are offering
in-person instruction,
more than 4,400 K-12 schools
shifted to remote learning
or closed for at least one day last week.
Mainly due to COVID-19
related staffing issues.
- What happens then is the school says,
okay, well, let's, let's find a substitute
for the teacher who isn't there.
But the problem is that
that has also created a
shortage among substitutes.
- [Narrator] To help with
the school staffing crunch,
some states are stepping in.
- The greatest need right now
today, is substitute teachers.
- [Narrator] Dr. Kurt Steinhaus,
is among the New Mexico State Officials,
who spearheaded the Supporting Teachers
and Families initiative,
which asks state workers
and National Guard members
to volunteer to become licensed
as substitute teachers.
- These National Guard
members are community members.
They're coaches, they're parents,
they know their communities.
- [Narrator] Since winter break,
around 60 school districts and
charter schools in New Mexico
have moved into remote learning.
Dr. Steinhaus, said the state is short
more than a thousand substitutes.
Less than a week after
the program was announced,
46 National Guard members were
already deployed to schools.
- These National Guard
members who are substituting,
they're not just in there,
just randomly doing something,
they're following the classroom
teacher's lesson plan.
- [Narrator] Other states
have taken similar steps.
Oklahoma Governor Kevin Stitt,
signed an executive order last Tuesday,
allowing state workers to
retain their regular jobs
while working in the classroom.
Since then more than 200 state employees
have signed up to become
substitute teachers.
- They'll be able to step in
with assistance from the schools
and be able to continue
that learning process.
- [Narrator] In California,
Governor Gavin Newsom,
signed an order aimed at reducing
the barriers for districts
to hire short-term substitute teachers.
- We just did an executive order this week
to allow flexibility with substitutes
and continue to allow
retirees to come back,
to help us with staffing
shortages in the immediate
to get through the next few weeks,
because we must keep our kids
in-person safely in school.
- [Narrator] Connecticut
has also cleared a path
for retired teachers to fill in,
by allowing them to work without
losing retirement benefits.
The Kansas State Board of Education,
temporarily eased requirements
for getting an emergency
substitute license.
And in late December, Michigan
Governor, Gretchen Whitmer,
signed a bill to allow school
secretaries and other staff
to work as substitutes.
- While it's great to find a substitute
for a teacher who's not there,
the ideal scenario is for that
the teacher, him or herself to be there.
- [Narrator] As elected officials
and school administrators
push to continue in-person learning,
many acknowledged that
relying on substitute teachers
is not the perfect solution.
- Substitute teachers
perform a valuable role,
but the fact of the matter is
they are not the classroom
teacher who knows the kids
and knows where they
are with their material.
- You should automatically
know that that equals, five.
- The staff shortages at both
the teacher and the sub level,
I think the combination is
raising some fresh concerns
about kids maybe falling
behind in their education,
at a time when there is
already widespread agreement
that remote learning was
bad for a lot of kids
when it comes to their academics.
- [Narrator] While the
statewide top-down approaches
are intended to address the
immediate need for teachers,
it will take time before schools get back
to pre pandemic staffing levels,
even as COVID-19 cases decline
in some parts of the country.
- There's no sense of mission accomplished
where we're in the clear,
but there is the sense that
we can get back to something
that more resembles normal,
which they want for their kids
who have had anything but
that for almost two years now.
(soft music)